now I want to talk about something
pretty near and dear to my heart here at
the top of the show okay folks I'm very
happy with the success of the show I've
gotten a lot of gratification but Andy
you're aware of this there's one thing
that I one dream I never fulfilled one
thing that never came my way that I
always hoped and that's up I always
dreamed of being a teen idol I always
thought that being a teen idol would be
the coolest thing in the world and you
know and and it never happened for me I
used to read those magazines when I was
a kid
Tiger Beat teen beat and think wouldn't
it be cool if I was on the cover of one
of those and look a lot of stuff to come
my way I'm not complaining but that
eluded me you know this actually is
almost borders on mental illness yeah
yeah yeah this is like setting fires and
cruelty to animals right right this is
at which of two other things which I
enjoy and so I well why would people get
behind that Bernie yeah all right well
anyway I always wanted to be a teen idol
so recently I decided I'm gonna stop
wishing I'm gonna try and do something
about it so I I went out of my way to
try and become a teen idol one day
earlier this week and we'll take a look
at what happened
[Music]
make me more appealing what's your
advice what do I what's the story what
do you think do I sing I see I do sing
actually have a very we do they like
singing I have a very very high and
pretty voice
[Music]
you don't hear that a lot these days
never say I like a girl that's really
hot beautiful why because that makes
girls say it I like a girl with a snice
personality and humor wait a minute let
me get this straight
I like braces I like girls with bad
eyesight I'm crazy about bad skin is Leo
still big now tell me if I'm wrong I've
noticed that Leo and Titanic
good-looking I understand why other
girls go crazy for him
what are the pictures I've seen recently
Leo space is starting to puff out isn't
there a chance that he's three years
away from looking like Ernest Borgnine
that's that's not a problem I have a
small patch of hair sort of where my ass
meets my back well can I ask you
something is this is this AJ right here
so how much longer is his ride do you
think and start him does anyone want to
go on the record or I mean how many
years away is he from being barricaded
in a motel with three hookers and a
shotgun
[Music]
what could I wear that would make a
thirteen-year-old say that guys dabomb
dabomb yeah you have to get rid of these
you know these were my grandfather's
what are you talking about that's a
problem that's that's kind of a problem
okay so what do I wear
kind of like sneakers that you add that
look actually used I mean not that these
don't look used that is legitimately sad
these are the shoes afford a drunk no
really
drummers crazy I noticed he needs ridwan
and a gun you know seriously just shoot
him with a rhino gun like 500-yard he's
younger than you
yeah yes he's like 10 or 11 nine yeah
I've heard no he he's started with the
band when he was a fetus actually
you don't know any that emails from my
day like Scott Baio you ever heard of
him
I think I've heard his last name yeah
fail no as familiar yeah do you ever
watch Charles in Charge when you were
growing up it was a child he was yeah
yeah you know the song to Charles in
Charge days and our night Charles in
charge of our wrongs and our rights I
want Charles in Charge oh that's crazy
that I know that right because when that
show was on it was like 25 I don't know
there was the art art in ireri she lunch
at 1:00 lunch at Planet Hollywood Wow
yeah with the z100 contest one or twenty
five-year-old girl one time no I just
get in the way oh no I'm like the guy in
the backseat of the car the nerd no it's
fine you go ahead the fact that you're
actually inviting me to be the third
wheel is making me want to kill myself
looks I do sexy I'm not great at you
know I do more sort of oh my god he
looks queasy you know it's just sexy i
okay sexier
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
I'm a rock star but a hint of Sigmund
Freud is this segment right this shirt
you can see everything and my hair my
body hair is coming through the shirt
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the cat was not harmed I just want to
make it clear that little kitten was not
harmed
it just doesn't smell so good now take a
break when we come back Jon Stewart's
gonna join us stick around we got a
great show